i don't even know how we are in this
position right now shan i thought you
were gonna take it all
i know what happened
you know it's funny everyone keeps
saying you know her game tank because
she stopped listening to people but it's
like i really believe that my game
started to go a little bit downhill
because i was listening to too many
people you know i really like i gave to
sean what he wanted i gave ricard what
he wanted and neither of those decisions
were good for my game but i just you
know i i wanted to i wanted to listen
because you know deshaun had made a big
thing about me not listening to him and
um so i just i i don't know i just i've
learned a lot from just like oh my
goodness but it yeah it's super
emotional time right now for sure
were you shocked to see ricard
campaigning against you immediately
after you warned him that desean and
danny were going to go after him because
you were so genuine with that and he
just turned around and it's like my time
to get shan yeah i mean i think like i
will always say like it was the best
move of the season because i i was going
to win that game like there was nobody's
gonna stop me i was gonna put my my foot
to the pedal and i was gonna go to the
end and i think ricardo knew that even
if he sat beside me in final two he
wasn't gonna win deshawn knew the same
thing i think and um that's because i
worked my little tail off you know um
but i think it was hard to see ricard
campaigning against me but at the same
time the gamer the strategist in me was
like it was a good move it was the best
move of the season and i love that boy
um you know he is my gay husband i say
and uh the will to my grace i love him
um that's my boo and so at the end of
the day like he did what he needed to do
he was strategic he was smart so i can
applaud that but it did take me a little
bit of time to get over it you know
because it's just hard um but yeah like
it was hard but ricardo's who he is and
i was who i am you know and um
you know it's like the what are they
called the scorpion and the swan you
know like kind of riding across it's
like i'm carrying you i'm carrying you
and then i get to this why did you take
me out because it's what i do it's you
know it's who we are but so you know no
bad blood
did you suspect it at all because you
guys were just having that conversation
about oh it's too soon to talk about
when we're gonna take each other out
when we'll have to go against each other
did you have any gut feeling
i mean like the truth is is that like
you know desean had promised on you know
on everything he had sworn the culture
like he was like you know i'm in for the
all black alliance i i did the same you
know i never thought in a million years
anyone would flip from there and ricard
i knew just didn't have the
relationships i knew that people just
didn't want to work with him and that
there was a lot of strain there and so i
didn't think that he could pull it off
and yet i knew i was a target at the
merge i knew it was a target at the
merge um
but it was like you know that moment at
the fire of the pizza under the stars
you know it's like this kind of moment
of like you know um like will you go to
prom with me kind of thing right like
he's saying in front of xander and
heather we don't have a final two and in
that moment i'm thinking i want you to
be my final two i don't know how it's
going to work with all black alliance
but i i love you like i want to go far
you know and uh i thought that was the
only moment i acted in fear and i didn't
ask him to be final two with me the only
moment and that's the one moment i may
regret uh but
you know i i didn't have any inkling
because when i got back like i was
actually pretty sick that whole
afternoon i was with medical you know so
um
it was like people like did she not play
be kurt idle because of ego you know was
it that she thought you know it's like
no it wasn't any of that i was sick that
day i got back from medical with 10
minutes to tribal you know uh and i
wasn't feeling the best so it was like i
just was trying to recover even at
tribal council from what i was feeling
and so i wasn't reading the room i
didn't have any inkling that anything
was going to go down
it was a good blind side ricard was
right he was spot on
it seemed like so many people were drawn
to you this season as was the audience
for sure but even with brad telling you
he found the idol and then you even got
jd to give up the extra vote in a very
like mom son way
how
what do you think it was about you that
people were just so drawn to and just
felt like comfort and trust in
i mean i don't know that if you'd asked
me this like maybe weeks ago or even
before the game if i would have known
like did i have this ability i mean i
think all throughout my life i felt like
i i make deep relationships with people
i love deep relationships um and i try
to be as authentic with people in the in
my real in my life right and that's why
relationships run deep is when you offer
authenticity and it's reciprocated um
all i can tell you is that when i was in
the game
i was my absolute full self and i very
rarely told lies you know i i sat with
people i listened to them and i shared
my story they shared theirs with me and
i paid attention and i um i think when
people feel like you're listening and
you can
speak back what they've shared with you
they feel a sense of mirroring they feel
a sense of connectivity there um they
feel heard they feel seen which is just
ironic because it's like if i wasn't a
good listener i wouldn't have gotten
this far on the game right but so i'm
like spending a lot of time with these
people and i and my what felt like i
absolutely see a father and brad he
taught me how to scuba dive he taught me
how to uh go snorkeling he taught me how
to like build a fire and shelter like i
did all that with brad stuff i never did
with my dad i you know i was in foster
care for a while like you know so this
was a really real relationship genie
like she i love her i love her story
like i root for her you know my heart
beats for her sarah same thing you know
super sweet jd little kid brother and
yet at the same time i'm gonna take that
candy from the baby you know what i mean
like so i
like i don't i i i think people
felt close to me because i was real and
authentic with them and yet at the same
time you know i knew i'm gonna be myself
in this game but i'm also gonna make
hard decisions and if you give me an
inch i'm going to take a mile so
that was the way i chose to play my game
i know it was a little controversial
being a pastor everyone's like how could
a pastor be like
freaking out everywhere it's like i
don't play
survivor like a pastor i don't play uno
like a pastor i'm playing a game you
know so um yeah i mean i i love the
relationships that i made and i know
that everyone i think even liana and
danny felt like i was their number one i
i you know and ricard you know was the
only person that i didn't promise that
so anyways yeah
your song we have to talk about your
song did you think it was gonna blow up
as big as it did because people on
twitter were like oh shan this is like
iconic
girl no i did not let me tell you
something about that
one of the last questions right was um
do you have any quirks and i was like
well i do this one really stupid thing
that my best friend says they're like
they're like what is that i was like oh
i kind of hum when i'm like thinking
really intently about something or i'm
like up to no good and they're like oh
what does it sound like i was like no
and they were like please can we hear it
and so i did it i did it and then they
asked me to do it again i was like oh no
this might become a thing and it sure
enough became a thing and i had no idea
you know like i thought joe was lying to
me like he was like i'm gonna put some
violins under it and i was like ha ha
you know like i don't believe that
you're gonna actually do that little did
i know first episode i'm out there
humming and people were like did she
really hung that loud heck no i don't
hum that loud like what that's craziness
you know but um it's great like the
shanthum they call it
it's so cute
but uh i never thought i'd get a i mean
honestly they did so right by me i i
can't be upset you know i if i was gonna
go out anyway this was gonna be i love
cbs i love production they were
fantastic and so i mean what more could
i ask for you know oh gosh that song's
gonna be a death of me though ah
you really gave off main character vibes
for this whole season how do you feel
about your edit because like you were in
every single episode basically and you
were just so entertaining to watch
i mean i think like
honestly uh like katie it's like up and
down like watching yourself
on tv like with that much screen time
like you know talking to my cast mates
here and there they're like you should
be so happy you're like main characters
like that's not exciting for me like way
too much attention so like when you get
to that state like you only can go down
from there you know i mean like and
people can only take shots from you like
because they're like oh because they can
point out all these little flaws that
they think about your game pick your
gameplay apart and you know it's like i
don't know sometimes i wonder would it
have been better to be more hidden you
know i don't know um i definitely
playing the game didn't think i was
gonna get this much air time um am i
glad about it i don't know it has been
an up and down experience um watching
yourself on national television and then
you know all the good this i'm probably
80 good but that 20 bad is like oh my
god that sounds so loud you know and i'm
like was i that i had to go back and ask
my pastor and my friends and my family
do i not listen to you do you feel like
i don't listen to you like do you feel
like i'm like not paying attention do
you think i always get my way and
they're all like shan
no like we know who you are but i mean
for real like i struggled with that for
a minute and
like i would be so quiet over
thanksgiving i was so quiet and
my uh you know my family was like why
are you so quiet like i'm just really
trying to listen to everything
everyone's trying to say right now
well you know it was a main character
vibes for sure i i i think i got a sense
of health production felt about me and i
feel good about that you know so well
you were representing canada too so we
love to see it love to see it i love me
and we love to see right we love to see
it
so this is the hardest season of
survivor so far what was the hardest
part for you
i mean did you see the way i lost it
over that papaya did you see the land
lost it over that grilled cheese girl we
didn't get no rice we didn't get nothing
okay like it was we had to work for
every single thing and people were like
oh that's not a survivor they're only
out there for 26 days it's like what
with no food and this girl has ms and
very little like weight to lose out
there like i was like trying to bulk up
you know get like uh jeans like damn it
you know like you know but like and
honestly it was hard it was hard like i
i for the first maybe 10 days i was fine
but after that i was like i'm going a
little crazy um that was hard i think
the heat was hard i think the
the challenges were harder
um
yeah that those things made it really
really hard and uh you know i came
expecting to play a particular game and
it was just it was it was very different
than what i anticipated yeah
do you regret anything at all
the only thing i regret is that my mom
wasn't alive to see me play um because
she passed away in 2017 um and that's
the only thing that i really regret but
you can't change that if i and
we're talking gameplay i don't regret a
single thing because i played my heart
out left everything out there the only
moment that i acted in fear and i don't
even know if i regret it because i would
have gone with the black alliance right
but the only moment i acted in fear was
one i didn't ask ricard to the prom was
when i didn't say will you be final two
with me you know what i mean um because
i was too scared i thought he would
shoot me down i thought he would be like
no no let's go separately you know
um i really felt that insecurity and
it's so funny how those insecurities
will just travel with you through life
but uh that was the moment that was the
moment for me that i if i had to
pinpoint one thing that would be it it
wasn't taking ricardo over jeannie
because genie was way too honest of a
player even though i love her that'll be
my girl to the end of time but i
couldn't bring janie with me because she
was just too honest and uh so ricard was
the right move um but
yeah he struck first and you brutus
that's how i feel you know
i've spoken to a lot of people who have
left survivor so
when i ask the question based on game
play who do you think should win
everyone says shan
so for you based on gameplay who do you
think should win
and this is gameplay alone gameplay
alone ricard he's gone to tribal he and
i have gone to tribal every single day
he's had to navigate just as much as i
have um i probably a bit more than him
because you know but he had to navigate
a lot too and this move i think was the
game-breaking move and i think it was
probably the best move of the season he
was wise to do it so i think ricardo
should win at this point everybody else
is just hiding and everybody else is
just lucky at this point yeah
what advice would you give people who
want to be on survivor and like it's
their life dream oh go go play if you
want to play survivor go do it go apply
don't make a corny tik tok video they're
not gonna look at that but actually tell
your story you know be about something
you know don't expect that if you're
kind of just bumming around and living
in the basement of your mom's house like
that they're gonna be like
hey let's cast them like be about
something make sure you have a job make
sure you have a life you know you've got
you've got a story to tell about you
know not that a job means any i'm just
saying you know in this climate because
unemployment is a thing i just mean make
sure you're living life when you you
know when you make your video you know
you've got to have something that's
interesting you know about you and i
would just say
yeah go pursue your dreams like life is
too short to sit on the sidelines and be
like ah they'll never cast me like go
like it was me you know i'm like this
little bold legged like
like foster kid from toronto with like
came from a crazy background like if i
can do it y'all can do it you know so
and my last question for you is if you
could sum up your whole survivor
experience what would you say about it
ah
redeeming it was redemptive
yeah because i went up there with ms and
i went out there at a time in my life
when i thought i was no longer strong
and courageous because i had just gone
through eight rounds of chemo i felt
like a shell of myself i you know had
this disease my mom died you know i was
in the middle of job switching from one
job to one denomination to another you
know it was community loss moving into a
new community i was just like so much
happening in my life and i just really
was like man
where's that kick-ass girl that i was
when i was 16 i mean i was living on the
streets but i just had so much energy
and you know like i was just so much
braver and like tackling more and like
where is that energy you know and uh
survivor gave me the opportunity to
really integrate all all aspects of like
my personhood my experience my life my
calling and uh and my disease you know
and to really just not be afraid of my
disease and to know like yeah i may have
a flare-up i may not but this is not the
end of me this diagnosis is not the end
of me my mom's death is not the end of
me you know um god willing i will see
her again and um yeah and i will i will
free of flare-ups this is my hope you
know so yeah
you